this video is sponsored by book Walker
if something happens that forces you to
confront your own mortality where do you
even start with that who can you even
turn to that's not a question I hope any
of you will have to face in the near
future as I'm sure most of us are pretty
content with just living our daily lives
but if something like that were to
happen in the face of death how
desperately would you search for that
meaning in your life wow that was a
really morbid start to the video you
know you know I'm sure there's a better
way to put this Michael you explain it
hey Vsauce Michael here when will you
die today I wanted to talk about I want
to eat your pancreas which is a story
that explores exactly that mchugh anime
girls searching for a meaning in life
just before our own death and I would
call that massive spoilers if it didn't
open up with her damn funeral this is a
title that comes in the form of an anime
a manga or a light novel and a
live-action movie so yeah just just take
your pick really do you like animation
pictures words or weird creatures who
inhabit this strange world that looks
like a less aesthetic Makoto Shinkai
movies now for those of you who'd never
heard of this anime before I'm sure
there's a bunch of raised eyebrows up
what the title of this movie implies as
in the medium where just about every
niche kink is accounted for one wouldn't
be blamed for thinking finally the anime
I was waiting for a story about the
human desire to consume the insulin
organ but fortunately this anime has
nothing to do with the consumption of
body parts and joins the ranks of Rosco
does not dream of bunny girls Empire in
the latest trend of anime titles trying
their best to literally clickbait an
audience into watching them so three
years down the line don't be surprised
if posters start looking like this the
story actually revolves around two
people the cheerful Sakura and are
gloomy main boy who I can't name due to
small spoilers who one day by chance
happens upon Sakura's diary in a
hospital wholesomely titled living with
dying where she explains to him that
she's a normal girl living a pretty
normal life where she goes to school and
hangs out with friends and doesn't do
anything out of the ordinary
oh also she has the cancer well it's
never actually explicitly spayed to the
others cancer and referred to as some
sort of pancreatic disease but who the
hell is knowledgeable about terminal
pancreatic diseases
not exactly vs tier power ranking of the
terminal illness world where like lung
and liver are the cancer rock stars with
all the attention they get upon finding
out this fact he agrees keep it a secret
as she hasn't told any of the close
friends and through the shared secret
they find a small bond that slowly grows
as we follow the duo in the final months
leading up to Sakura's death and the
precious time they spend with each other
as she searches for a conclusion in her
life the quote I want to eat your
pancreas comes from an old superstition
that if there was something wrong with a
certain body part if you eat that same
body part then it'll get better
so that's where the name comes from
nothing too ridiculous but in my mind I
still find it amusing that some non
anime fans out there will be searching
for the lyrics to I want to break free
on Google when they randomly see what
but I'm not your nurses isn't exactly a
topic that's new in film and television
given that it's a pretty easy issue to
revolve drama around someone has a
disease that will cause them to die then
they die and it's sad death aside so
many aspects can now be seen as cliche
given the popularity of teen cancer
romance dramas like a Fault in Our Stars
which tried it's best to talk of my
heartstrings but I can never quite shake
the feeling of points that the writing
seems more guarded towards the preteen
twilight demographic which is why it
never fully connected with me I should
probably go to speak ok ok ok perhaps
okay will be our always okay so how does
pancreas separate itself from its
predecessors well on the surface not
much I mean if you look at the plot
description it does have its cliches to
the point where you'd be able to spell
out the basic plot points in some cheesy
early two-thousands trailer voice light
in a world where two people have nothing
in common I have cancer that's cool I
don't hopefully God we have like nothing
in common our relationship can bloom in
the most unlikely of places I know you
like dying and stuff but would you go to
homecoming with me of course I will I
want to eat your pancreas way way way
way what what the hell did you say
perhaps I want to eat your pancreas will
be our always so there's nothing overly
complex I can really say about the plots
aside from one thing the movie plays out
pretty much
exactly the way you think it would and
even though there is an attempt to shake
things up it doesn't change anything of
consequence in the grand scheme of
things but I thought it worked in spite
of this because of the subtleties
there's kind of easily divulged into the
cheesy romance cancer drama we've all
seen before but one of the aspects I
enjoyed was the fact that the
relationship that was explored between
our leads was way more complex than
purely a romantic one sure there's a bit
of romance involved but this isn't the
tragic story of the socially awkward guy
finding the dying camps bale of of his
dreams it's far more focused on human
connection and what we yearn for with
our relationships with other people and
the dynamic between our leads is what
this is entirely focused around they are
the backbone of everything the entire
story revolves around them and they are
what the movie excuse the morbidly
accurate pun lives and dies by the story
portrays them as polar opposites that
intrinsically balance each other out our
main guy someone who doesn't care for
other people's so much so he's never had
anything close to resembling a friends
or even a personal connection with
anyone while Sakura is the confident
outspoken anime girl who's never afraid
to share her mind yes he wasn't
introvert she was an extrovert can I
make it any more obvious it might not be
a new idea to have two polar opposite
people form an unlikely friendship but
the character development here is
handled absolutely beautifully that I
wouldn't have it any other way what more
can I say okay so I was stopped wearing
it now she is his first real connection
he's ever had and he brings her a sense
of normalcy in her life but while there
might be the initial reason they hang
out you see a subtle shift as they
slowly start to depend on each other
influence each other and without
noticing it reach a point where they
aspire to be like one another he learns
a value of forming a bond with other
people and she and Vees the ability to
have urinal law without the need for
anyone else together there's a sense of
completion like two sides of the same
coin never quite able to grasp to the
other side yet intrinsically linked
forever in an existence of perfect
balance in the end of the relationship
they share isn't one of romantic
partners but it's not one of friendship
either it's a complex connection that's
hard to put into words though suffice to
say they become two people very
important to each other who also rely on
each other
and it's in seeing this connection form
and the beautiful imprinting was able
to leave and both of them that in the
end was the huge factor that moved me to
the point of Tears because despite the
fact I've been using humor in this video
and more or less talked about everything
in a light-hearted manner I'd be lying
if I said it didn't hit me because it
did the thing I related to was the main
character's journey as someone who grew
up has that awkward antisocial kid who'd
rather spend all his energy watching
anime rather than making friends seeing
someone find the beauty of discovering
that right connection to another person
certainly made me reflect on every life
I had encountered that shaped me into
the better person I think I am today and
how every one of them had left their own
mark on me in some way it's when I
started to understand what the film was
trying to say that the huge elephant in
the room slowly crept its way out of the
shadows into plain sight
she's going to die and it's only a
matter of time before it happens call it
a trope call it a cliche but it doesn't
change the gravity of that fact whether
it be in real life or in a fictional
story knowing this we start to mirror
the main character we erect a wall to
prevent ourselves from getting hurt and
yet as they spends more time with each
other and you cautiously open yourself
up something seems off it's not the fact
that she seems like someone who's going
to die it's the fact that she doesn't
there's just something about her
infectious charm that makes you
impossible not to fall into her flow you
know you shouldn't grow attached but as
the finites runtime presses on like him
you realize crap you don't want that
inevitable thing to happen and even
though you know it's going to in the
moment as you see her joyfully smile it
just doesn't feel real Camila
Humira condonation know what truly moved
me with this movie wasn't her impending
fates for a film about terminal illness
little was actually spotlighted about
the physical toll of living with that
illness instead I was seeing just how
much a life can change a person
how will the right connection could give
me the conclusion you were looking for
because despite the topic that the plot
revolves around this isn't a story about
dying it's one about finding out what it
means to be living I'm sure many of us
now won't be in a stage where you have
to ponder about something as gloomy as
our own mortality but whether it be the
sudden death of someone you know and all
would relatively you realize you will
have to say goodbye too soon or yes
finding out someone has a terminal
illness there are times in life you
encounter that can serve as a heavy
reminder that no matter how far away it
may be this is an inevitable fate for
all of us and as morbid as that sounds
it doesn't have to be sometimes that
presence of death is the wake-up call we
need to reflect on life and the kind of
mark we were able to leave in the same
vein of attending someone's funeral
looking round and being able to see the
invisible footprints of everyone who
they've left a mark on in the time
they've spent on this earth this film
was the story of how two people were
able to leave a footprint on each
other's lives in the short time they
were able to have the death of a loved
one is never an easy thing to face and
everyone processes it differently
sometimes you hear the news or you're
standing there the funeral and it hasn't
properly hit you yet you logically know
they're not there anymore but it still
feels like some ethereal dream you're
going to wake up from and everything's
going to be as it was but there will be
a point when the gravity of the reality
truly hits you
maybe it's seeing their empty room for
the first time randomly getting a whiff
of the scent they used to have or
feeling the grooves on the couch they
used to sit on and knowing you'll never
see them sit in that same spot ever
again sometimes is not until that moment
of
realization that you're able to truly
appreciate how deep a footprint that
person was able to leave on your own
life
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you to book Walker for officially
sponsoring this I want to eat your
pancreas is available on their website
and both manga and light novel form so
if you want to experience this beautiful
story you can do so by clicking on the
link in the description if you're a
first-time user you can use coupon code
gig ugh you know how it works now get
five dollars off so you can get the
entire story for just a few bucks and I
think that's definitely worth it for a
title like this unless you don't like
feeling stuff anyway that's it for me
I've been gig up I hope you have a
wonderful day and I will see you all
next time